bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans cette vidéo où je voulais réagir à
une vidéo qui est parue récemment sur la
chaîne not bonus donc la 2uxè chaîne de
notabéet et cette vidéo de notabénet
s'intitule Les Femmes préhistoriques
savaient-elles chasser ou
pouvaient-elles chasser une vidéo qui
s'intéresse évidemment à la position de
la femme paléoliique euh dans la société
dans la société de son époque donc c'est
une vidéo qui réagit à des articles qui
ont été enfin un article le en
particulier qui a été publié en juin
2023 mais qui fait partie d'une série
d'articles publiés en juin 2023 qui ont
fait évidemment pas mal de bruit dans la
presse mais sur lequel sur lesquels je
m'étais pas vraiment arrêté pour les
Paléo news donc du coup c'est aussi pour
moi l'occasion de faire une petite
séance de rattrapage sur des paléos news
que je n'ai pas couvertes cette vidéo de
notabénz je ne vais pas la débunker il
s'agit pas d'un dbunk il s'agit en fait
de deux points que j'aimerais souligner
qui sont amenés dans la vidéo de notabé
mais qui je trouve sont pas suffisamment
développés et à mon avis méritent d'être
développé quand on parle justement du
sujet de la femme paléoliique de la
place de la femme paléolitiique dans la
société notamment au regard de la chasse
et donc la première chose qui à mon avis
mériterait d'être soulignée et qui à mon
sens ne l'est pas suffisamment dans les
débats en général parce que évidemment
cette vidéo elle cristallise beaucoup de
choses mais les débats en général euh
oubli de souligner un point extrêmement
important ce qui est questionné ça n'a
jamais été la capacité des femme
paléolithique à chasser entendu que la
chasse ça peut se ça peut être aussi
simple que voir une tortue et la
retourner sur le
dos ramasser des œufs relever des
collets tout ça ce sont des actes de
chasse et ce sont des actes de chasse
éminemment faciles à faire même pour une
femme enceinte ou une femme très très
âgé ou même pour un homme très âgé je
veux dire ou pour un enfant très jeune
dans la dans la société paléolitiique il
ne fait quasiment aucun doute que des
actes de chasse de la sorte pouvaient
être pratiqués par des femmes donc
est-ce que les femmes pouvaient chasser
la vraie question c'est en réalité
le gros
gibier C'est ça la vraie question alors
c'est effectivement amené dans la vidéo
de notabéné un peu tard dans la vidéo
alors qu'à mon avis c'est central donc
c'est pour ça que je voulais étaler à ça
à plat sur la table c'est-à-dire la la
question de est-ce que les femmes du
Paléolitique chassé ou non elle a
toujours été répondu par la positive ça
a toujours été mais oui évidemment que
oui évidemment que l'acte de chasser
peut-être pratiqué par absolument
n'importe qui à n'importe quel âge donc
oui les femmes Paléolitique pouvait
chasser évidemment qu'elle pouvait
chasser la question ça a toujours été la
chasse au gros gibier et c'est là que la
vidéo de notabet je trouve apporte des
réponses pertinentes notamment au regard
de la critique qu'ils font de cet
article alors critique qui soulligne les
points à la fois positif et négatif
évidemment mais la question a toujours
été celle de la chasse au gros giber ça
a tellement toujours été celle de la
chasse au gros gibier voilà quand on
pose la question quand on pose à Google
la question les femmes pouvaient-elles
chasser voilà voilà ce que Google vous
envoie comme image il vous envoie
l'image de quoi bah d'une femme en train
de chasser du gros gibier il vous il
vous renvoie pas une image l'image d'une
femme en train de de relever les
colollets il y a une charge une
véritable charge derrière cette notion
de chasse qui est que à chaque fois
qu'on parle de chasse on sous-entend
chasse au gros gibier or ce n'est pas
vrai si vous voyez des gens qui vous
disent oui évidemment les femmes
paléolitiques pouvaient chasser ils ont
raison les femmes paléoliiques pouvaient
chasser la question c'est celle de la
chasse au gros gibier et pourquoi y
a-t-il débat autour de cette question de
la chasse au gros gibier et bien c'est
parce que dans les sociétés de chasseur
cuilleurs modernes qui par principe
d'actualisme je vous rappelle que le
principe d'actualisme dans les science
archéologique et paléontologique c'est
le seul lien c'est la seule connexion
qu'on a avec la réalité autrement si on
se met à réfléchir sans appliquer le
principe d'actualisme on est dans le
délire le plus total ou du moins on
n'est pas forcément dans le délire le
plus total mais la porte est ouverte au
délire le plus total il y a rien qui
différenciera un raisonnement
raisonnable d'un raisonnement
complètement dingue si les deux
raisonnements ne refuse d'appliquer le
principe d'actualisme le le principe
d'actualisme c'est un garde-fou et donc
on est obligé d'appliquer le principe
d'actualisme à la question de la chasse
au gros gibier dans les sociétés
paléolithiques non pas parce qu'on croit
que les sociétés de chasseurs
cuueilleurs modernes sont primitive mais
parce que on n pas d'autre choix que de
regarder ce qu'on a aujourd'hui pour
comprendre comment était le passé et ça
encore une fois notaé le l'explique très
bien on ne pense pas que les sociétés de
chasseurs cuueilleur modernes sont
primitives on a juste pas le choix que
d'appliquer le principe d'actualisme
donc on applique le principe
d'actualisme et on regarde ce qui se
passe chez les sociétés de chasseurs
cuueilleurs modernes et qu'est-ce qu'on
voit bah que en fonction des études hein
évidemment il y a plusieurs études
entropologi qui ont été faites sur le
sujet en fonction des études il n'existe
que 1/ers voire même un car des sociétés
dans lesquelles les femmes participent à
la chasse au gros giibier avec euh de
groses guillemets autour du mot
participe parce que évidemment
participer à la chasse ne fait pas de
vous automatiquement le chasseur vous
pouvez être un rabatteur par exemple
mais pas négligable évidemment hein ça
ça existe les femmes chasseuses de gros
gibiier mais il n'y a qu'une minorité de
sociétés de chasseurs cuueilleurs
modnees qui applique qui qui qui
implique les femmes dans la chasse au
gros gibiier c'est un comportement qui
est majoritairement genré chez Homo
sapiens moderne donc il serait non
raisonnable de penser que Homo sapiens
du Paléolithique ne faisait pas pareil
par principe d'actualisme alors après il
va falloir chercher des preuves
archéologiques de ça il va falloir des
preuves archéologiques pour ou contre
d'ailleurs ça et il y en a pour et
contre mais c'est vrai que pour
l'instant le la dominante c'est plutôt
les hommes étai imp dans la chasse au
gros gibier pas les femmes et le
deuxième point que je voulais aborder
c'était la question du pourquoi pourquoi
est-ce que c'est controversé cette
question de les femmes chassaient-elles
ou pas le gros gibier au Paléolithique
pourquoi est-ce que c'est si important
bon bah là c'est effectivement quelque
chose qu'on a hérité des années 50 à
savoir que pour une raison que je vais
essayer de vous expliquer mais on verra
bien si j'y arrive mais en gros il y a
une raison pour il y a plusieurs raisons
pour lesquelles on considère que la
chasse au gros gibier c'est vachement
important pour les sociétés paléoliiques
enfin c'était vachement important pour
les sociétés paléolitiques il y a une
raison pour laquelle on considère que la
chasse au gros gibier c'est le pinacle
vous voyez de de de l'humanité quoi
c'est vraiment c'est le truc qui fait de
nous des êtres humains on chasse du gros
jibbier c'est voilà c'est important et
et en fait cette importance elle est
cette glorification on va même dire de
la chasse au gros gibier c'est pour
pourquoi est-ce que c'est important en
fait pourquoi ce serait important que
les femmes et participé à la chasse au
gros gibier ou pourquoi dans un prenant
l'autre point de vue pourquoi est-ce que
c'est important que les hommes aient
l'exclusivité de cette chasse au gros
gibier voilà prenons les deux points de
vue et c'est une question qui est
importante de se poser pourquoi est-ce
qu'on glorifie la chasse au gros gibier
parce que finalement le la chasse au
gros gibier qu'est-ce que c'est ça
rapporte certes une énorme quantité de
viande mais ça la rapporte d'un coup
alors ça rapporte pas que de la viande
ça rapporte aussi des des ossems et des
peaux certes euh mais ça rapporte une
grande quantité de ressources d'un coup
qu'une petite communauté ne va pas
forcément pouvoir
consommer avant que tout ça s moisisse
c'est extrêmement dangereux ça ça
toujours on a toujours été d'accord sur
le fait que la chasse au gros gibier
c'est extrêmement dangereux ça prend
très longtemps donc c'est pas une source
de nourriture très viable c'est certes
une source de nourriture d'ossement et
de peau mais qui peuvent être aussi
récupéré par
charognage c'est une source aussi de
nourriture qui va périmer très vite donc
ça va pas arriver souvent ça va arriver
en grande quantité ça va périmer très
vite du coup pourquoi est-ce qu'on
glorifie à ce point la chasse au gros
gibier alors qu'à côté de ça et là je
vais citer la chercheuse Ly Wadley qui
est une archéologue sud-africaine qui a
beaucoup travaillé sur le sujet qui a
fait une conférence récemment et qui du
coup m'a m'a inspiré cette vidéo euh qui
nous présentait des données absolument
absolument grandios absolument euh euh
qui qui ont vraiment changé ma façon de
percevoir la question en fait de de de
la chasse et de la cuueillette chez les
populations paléoliiques c'est line
Wadley nous présentait des données qui
montraient bien que la cuueillette
rapporte objectivement plus de calories
et de façon beaucoup plus régulière que
n'importe quelle activité de chasse au
gros giier vous irez voir vous irez voir
le profil de lin wadle sur Google
Scholar et lire sa littérature pour vous
en convaincre mais il y a pas beaucoup à
à réfléchir pour se dire que bah oui la
cuueillette étant une activité beaucoup
moins dans dangereuse vous pouvez y
aller plus souvent et rapporter plus de
calories et et de façon beaucoup plus
raisonnable et raisonnée que avec de la
chasse au gros gibier c'est-à-dire que
vous ramenez une quantité qui est
suffisante vous n ramenez pas plus vous
nen ramenez pas moins vous ramenez ce
qui est suffisant à à votre groupe et
vous en ramenez plus souvent parce que
c'est moins dangereux justement et parce
que plus de monde peut y participer
aussi donc la cuueillette c'est pas une
sous-activité ça rapporte plus de ça
rapporte objectivement plus de calories
et en plus ce qu'elle souligner c'est
que bah sachant que vous relevez les
collés que vous chopez des œufs que vous
retournez des tortues vous rapportez
aussi des protéines la cueillette ne
rapporte pas que des petits fruits et
que des racines des tubercules et tout
ça la cueillette rapporte aussi du
produit de la chasse ça rapporte aussi
des protéines et en réalité encore une
fois ce que nous disait linoad le c'est
que quand on regarde les société de
chasseurs cuilleurs modern des chasseurs
enfin des des cueilleurs du coup
rapportent suffisamment largement
suffisamment de protéines pour nourrir
tout le
monde chasse au gros gibier exclus dans
les sociétés moderne de
chasseurcueilleurs une fois de plus les
cueilleurs sont suffisamment efficaces
pour qu'on ait pas besoin des chasseurs
donc l'action de la chasse au gros
gibier n'est pas nécessaire à la survie
on n pas de moyen d'exclure hein je suis
pas en train de dire que c'est le cas
mais on n pas moyen d'exclure la
possibilité que la chasse au gros gibier
est était purement culturel à l'époque
du Paléolithique c'est-à-dire que ça que
ça a été une démonstration de force en
quelque sorte on n pas moyen d'exclure
la possibilité que la chasse au gros
gibier c'est que de l'esbrouf en fait et
ça moi j'ai trouvé ça mais PAF mind
blowing donc en réalité on a même pas
besoin de la chasse au gros gibier si
c'est pas nécessaire à la survie du coup
la sélection naturelle n'a n'a pas d'fit
c'est-à-dire que il est possible que la
chasse au gros gibier ait joué un rôle
négligeable dans l'évolution humaine et
c'est là où j'ai trouvé ça absolument
fou en fait alors quand vous pensez
justement que l'être humain devenu
carnivore soudainement voit ce flux de
protéines abreuver son cerveau et paf
c'est comme ça que le genre Homo devient
super intelligent bah d'un seul coup ça
ça vous remet tout ça en perspective
mais bien comme il faut alors vous savez
qu'en plus je suis très réceptif à ce
genre de chos puisque ça fait longtemps
que j'arrête pas de répéter que les les
protéines c'est pas ce qu' a de plus
important c'est le sucre qui est plus
important pour le fonctionnement du
cerveau mais certes on pourrait arguer
que les protéines servent à construire
le cerveau donc allez admettons mais bon
il se trouve que il faut du sucre aussi
et donc la cueillette est au moins aussi
importante que la chasse même en prenant
pour le principe que la chasse au gros
gibier est extrêmement importante la
chasse apporte les protéines mais la
cueillette va vous apporter les sucres
et vous avez besoin desux
les protéines pour construire le cerveau
les sucres pour l'alimenter maintenant
si en plus vous partez du principe que
la chasse c'est pas forcément hyper
utile enfin la chasse au gros gibier est
pas forcément hyper utile bah la
cuueillette comme je l'ai dit rapporte
suffisamment et de sucre et de protéines
pour faire fonctionner et alimenter
notre cerveau et lui permettre de
devenir le gros cerveau que que nous
avons aujourd'hui la cueillette peut
alimenter l'évolution du cerveau elle
toute seule la cuueillette peut avoir eu
son importance aussi au niveau de la
sortie d' d'Afrique puisque elle a
découvert dans une grotte daté enfin
dans des dépôts de grottes en Afrique du
Sud daté de 170000 ans ce que l'in wedle
a découvert ce sont des tubercules des
tubercules cuits ce qui veut dire que
Homo sapiens en tout cas l'ancêtre
d'Homo sapiens qui vivait il y a 170000
ans donc on est juste avant l'origine
d'Homo sapiens moderne euh Homo sapiens
anatomiquement archaïque et bien ces
ancêtres d'Homo sapiens utilisaient une
plante dont vous voyez ici une photo
avec son tubercule ici qu'il cuisinait
qu'il mangeait donc preuve directe de
cueillette hein chez un être humain du
Paléolithique ça déjà c'est acté mais en
plus cette plante elle a l'avantage
d'être distribuée depuis la pointe de
l'Afrique jusqu'au Moyen-Orient enfin
jusqu'en Arabie ici alors normalement
elle va même un peu plus loin jusqu'au
Moyen-Orient et du coup cette plante
c'est une source de nourriture fiable
facile à trouver facile à prélever qui
permet qui trace un chemin le long de la
côte Est de l'Afrique jusqu'en Asie
170000 ans on est juste avant la sorti
d'Homo sapiens d'Afrique juste avant la
sortie d'Afrique d'Homo sapiens et vous
avez cette plante donc qui trace des
petits pointillers conduisant Homo
sapiens jusqu'en Asie donc ce qu'elle
propose c'est que bah au-delà même de du
du simple fait que bah cette plante a pu
nourrir nos ancêtres elle a pu les
nourrir pendant leur sortie d'Afrique
voire même elle a pu les guider dans
leur sortie d'Afrique c'est pas une
preuve directe que c'est comme ça que ça
s'est passé évidemment mais c'est
intéressant c'est intéressant parce que
ça nous suggère qu'en fait bah là c'est
c'est la c'est la cueillette qui aurait
pu jouer un rôle prépondérant dans la
sortie d'Afrique d'Homo sapiens c'est
aussi c'est aussi un petit peu le début
de l'agriculture si vous voulez c'est
parce que évidemment c'est plus simple
avec les plantes c'est quand même
vachement plus simple de les replanter
de les replanter au même endroit et si
vous savez que ça va repousser à cet
endroit-là l'année d'après bah Vous vous
revenez quoi et c'est le début de
l'agriculture donc cette plante en plus
elle pourrait même expliquer comment
enfin le le fait que les êtres humains
utilisaient cette plante il y a 700000
ans c'est aussi le l'embron d'une
explication sur pourquoi est-ce qu'au
bout d'un moment on a fini par devenir
des agriculteurs la cuueillette c'est
quand même quelque chose qui a un
pouvoir explicatif sur l'évolution
humaine qu'il faut arrêter de négliger
en comparaison à la chasse au gros
gibier de là à dire que la cuueillette
est plus importante que la chasse dans
l'évolution humaine je vais pas aller
jusque là c'est pas ça que je veux dire
mais il faut quand même considérer la
possibilité que oui l'accueillette c'est
c'est pas une c'est pas une
sous-activité et à côté de ça comme le
souligne notabéné la femme qui reste
dans la grotte pour s'occuper des des
enfants pareil c'est pas ce serait pas
une sous-activité non plus ce serait pas
une sous-activité non plus c'est au
contraire c'est s'occuper des enfants et
de l'éducation et et là je je je vais
employer des grosses guillemets mais
même si la femme paléoliique ne se
limitait que à ce rôle j'emploie des
grosses guillemets mais même en
admettant ça même en admettant que la
société paléoliique était très très très
genrée et que les hommes ça chassait et
que les femmes ça s'occupait des gamins
et et ça faisait la vaisselle dans la
grotte je veux dire s'occuper des
enfants s'occuper de l'éducation c'est
l'activité la plus intellectuellement
importante dans la vie d'un être humain
ça a certainement eu plus d'influence
sur l'évolution humaine que n'importe
quelle autre activité comment
pouvez-vous argumenter que la chasse a
plus d'importance sur l'évolution du
cerveau que
ça c'est c'est ça n'a pas de sens donc
même en prenant une distribution hyper
genré des des rôles au paléolithiqu mais
même là ça n'a pas de sens de dire que
la ça n'a pas de sens de glorifier la
chasse au gros gibier en fait ça c'est
c'est ça à mon avis la grande question
et c'est ça à mon avis qui manquait un
petit peu dans la vidéo de notabéé et
c'est pour ça que je voulais faire cette
vidéo pour rajouter une petite couche
par-dessus de de de réflexion comme ça
de philosophie alors évidemment je vous
invite à aller voir la vidéo de notabéné
pour comprendre d'où vient mon
raisonnement évidemment puisque c'est
quand même la base de de mon
raisonnement cette vidéo de notabéné
mais euh je voulais rajouter ces oui ces
deux éléments là par-dessus donc la la
question de pourquoi est-ce qu'on
glorifie la chasse euh et pourquoi du
coup c'est controversé et évidemment la
la question de de rappeler bah que c'est
la chasse au gros gibier qui est le
centre du débat et rien d'autre parce
que sinon évidemment que les femmes
préhistorique étaient des chasseuses
voilà c'est tout pour cette vidéo
j'espère qu'elle vous a plu et qu'elle
aura clarifié quelques petits éléments
de ce débat et je vous dis à très
bientôt sur notre chaîne salut